♪♪
I play horror games
a lot.
This show is basically
taking that
to the next level
and putting me
in the games.
Where are we going?
I don't know why
I signed up for this,
to be honest.
[laughs]
♪♪
Really impressed by
the scope
of the whole thing.
Usually, it's just me
in a room
with one camera,
and that's it.
Now, there was, like,
three cameras at me
at all times
and producers
and all that kind
of stuff
I'm not used to.
So, alright, guys,
so tech rehearsal's
at 5 o'clock.
PEWDIEPIE: I literally just
had to show up
and everything was
set up.
It was so much fun.
It's, like,
this whole thing
set up for me.
Yes!
I was super-impressed
by all the sets.
It really felt like
I was in a video game.
[Bleep]
Obviously, I knew what
I was getting into.
I knew I was set out
to be scared.
[screams]
But they never told me
anything about the show.
I never knew what
was gonna go on.
I was supposed to do,
like,
a health check-up
before the show,
an insurance thing,
they told me
that it was.
And then, all of a sudden,
I'm sitting there
in a hospital
and all these
insane thing happen.
[growling]
But my health is fine.
You all did
an amazing job,
obviously.
I think you succeeded
scaring PewDiePie.
[clapping]
I really did have
the time of my life
and I'm so glad
I did it
'cause it was just
super-cool.
That's it, folks.
I can't wait for you
to see this.
It's gonna be awesome.
♪♪
I still don't fully
trust that
it's over.
People just set cameras
in front of me,
I'm never safe.
♪♪